la retraite j'y pense parce et c'est
très loin pour moi peut-être que je
devrais j'y crois pas trop pour moi en
tout cas au vu de comment les choses
évoluent dc est ce que moi je suis en
âge avoir la retraite je pense pas qu'on
sera toujours dans le même système
on devrait plus mobilisée pour le climat
justement c'est quelque chose de plus
important parce que c'est notre survie
c'est notre planète comme l'a par
exemple pour l'australie c'est non on
n'entend pas parler en fait alors que
les retraites on entend tout le temps
parler ils pensent un peu ke c'est
peut-être fort ce que je dis mais ouais
c'est un peu de l'égoïsme parce que le
climat ça les touche pas directement
parce qu'ils sont pas impactés alors que
les retraites massa tombent directement
sur leur compte en banque quoi fin c'est
leur vie c'est normal après c'est
quelque chose de très important à vrai
dire non je comprends pas vraiment
vraiment grand chose j'ai pas tout
compris parce que commande et je trouve
que c'est pas une réforme très
compréhensible honnêtement si j'ai bien
compris donc ira revenu à 1000 euros
normalement il y aura des points des
points de retraite
il y aura un bonus malus il me semble un
certain âge mois qui suivent en
pâtisserie bas on a regardé un peu avec
les profs ça change pas grand chose
- travailler plus longtemps mais après
on s'est engagé dans une filière on
savait qu'on a un beau si longtemps nous
on en hôtellerie-restauration donc on se
voit pas en cuisine ou en salle jusqu'à
60 ans c'est quand même assez physique
coiffe 1,67
[Musique]
le gouvernement veut supprimer
il